so
so this uh work is inspired by sorry
first of all i'm very happy to be here
thanks for inviting me
this work is inspired by the following
societal problem which is participating
democracy
and the idea here is that it's a process
emphasizing the role of citizen
involvement in political decision making
so instead of making decisions in a
small committee could you possibly make
decisions at this scale could you make
decisions in groups of 100
a thousand a million or a billion right
and the technical uh problem which
corresponds to this societal problem is
the same making its scale
so you could imagine this is making a
scale as being primarily voting so for
example you could have a simple poll
could be you could ask obama or romney
right and you either you vote for one or
the other
an example of a more complex process a
more complex decision that you might
want to make is something like how can
we cut the us budget deficit
and if you pose this problem on any
bulletin board on any public bulletin
board what's going to happen
is that there's like some guy is going
to say well you guys all convinced other
guys someone is going to call you
a bloody capitalist and then
and then some people are going to just
sort of smile retweet and nothing's
actually going to happen right
and so the question is can you design
algorithms
mechanisms and platforms for essentially
being able to get a coherent answer to
questions of this type
from a reasonably well informed crowd
so how can we make decisions at scale in
the face of polarization and extreme
opinions
and the problem of course is that free
form discussion boards often degenerate
into vitriol nothing
one person says something really extreme
and then that's where the conversation
hits
so what we need are is not just free
from discussion boards but we need our
more structured modes of interaction
with some provable properties
and so just to show how badly we are
polarized right there there isn't even
an agreement on whether we are polarized
or not
this is sort of a big set of results
which says
that we are highly polarized there's
also another set of results which says
we are not really polarized right
there's third set of people who actually
think that polarization is good
so
so our solution of this problem right is
to be a bit of an ostrich
which is uh let's not actually worry
about whether there's polarization
i mean sorry that's also our societal
societal decision about this problem to
be a bit of an ostrich
but also our personal decision about
this problem is to be a bit of an
ostrich
with a head in the sand which is we're
not trying to we're not going to try to
understand whether polarization happens
why it happens right so our goal is not
to sort of do science but to do
engineering
so we want the design systems and
algorithms which are going to lead to
decisions and not worry about whether
society is getting polarized or not
polarized
so
so here are some high level design goals
so when you do something like
participating democracy the way is
different from voting
is that the number of candidates is
equal the number of voters so you can
essentially assume that everyone has an
opinion and aggregate everyone's
opinions
no voter can look at all candidates
at scale and so that necessarily forces
you to have small group interactions and
a small group interaction could be
something as simple as you are shown two
opinions
and you are asked to choose between one
of the two right so for example similar
to what cigar was talking about you're
given two candidates
and you choose between one of the two
candidates
and you want to limit cognitive load
that you impose on anyone any one user
at any given time right because again
because people can't keep all these
different candidates in mind
we want to support not just voting but
also things like interaction
collaboration and discussion and you
want to align incentives
this is the high level design goals
and
the complexity parameter that we want to
look at for small group interactions
when you say we need small group
interactions one natural complexity
parameter is group size
and that's the one that i'm going to
focus on now how big or small does a
group need to be in some stylized
settings to be able to come to a
decision
and so today i'm going to talk about
this method
called triadic consensus this is
somewhat stylized
it's going to be a non-eximative
framework in the sense that i'm going to
describe
an algorithm
i'm not going to describe the axioms
that we're trying to
satisfy and the reason for that is i
don't
get the sense that we understand the
design space enough to lay out a bunch
of axioms and say we want the
decision-making process that is these
axioms
and if there's time remaining at the end
i'm going to describe two very other
different kinds of designs
which also try to solve the same part
problem and that would illustrate that
at least i don't think we are at a point
where we can lay down three exams and
say we want a system that satisfies
these three axioms
and in a later workshop the agt practice
workshop
i'm going to talk about non-stylized
systems i'm going to talk about systems
that we've actually built and deployed
and which are being used in dozens of
cities right now to do some form of
participating democracy and also
describe sort of broader research
directions and design philosophy but
today i'm going to focus on this
stylized model
and so the stylized model came from this
very simple experiment that we did
uh several years ago
where we divided we got a bunch of
people we asked them to self-identify as
well bring us a democrats
we ask them to make
budgets
and then we divide them into groups of
three and each group had either two
democrats and one republican
or two republicans and one democrat
and in each group we asked each member
to choose among the other two budgets
so a would be asked to choose among b
and c b would be associations among a
and c c would be our situations among a
and b
and what we realized was that
the the winners of these tended to be
just any just from our observation they
tend to be very reasonable budgets
they tend to be very nonpartisan so what
happened at least in that small scale
experiment there in a majority of the
groups the minority actually won so both
republicans voted for the democrat or
both democrats for it for the republican
and uh that's not that's not
a formal argument of any type is this an
ex it's just what sort of
made us think that perhaps this kind of
triadic voting uh is something which is
interesting
so the
what we're going to try to get towards
is the median of a group of opinions
so the famous example for this is that
sir francis dalton went at some village
asked people to gain to guess the weight
of an ox and it turned out the median of
the weights was actually a very good
approximation the median of the guesses
was a very good approximation to the
real weight of the off
and since that
that time people have typically thought
of the median of us
of a set of opinions as somehow the
consensus voice
so again uh like i said today we are
doing something stylized so our goal
would be to try to extract the median of
a group of opinions
and so there's a also a median voter
theorem which says that
if you can actually choose the median of
a bunch of values and reporting true
values in is incentive compatible
so the question that we're going to ask
is if you have something a bit more
complex than values on a line for
example if the question you want to ask
is what's the ideal way to regulate
off-road traffic
or
if you want to aggregate unstructured so
for example you want to aggregate some
unstructured estimates but it's not even
clear to you as a system designer
how to take the median of a bunch of
reported values
or where there's no consistent
vocabulary for a voter to express a
position then what do you do right
so in the weight of an ox everyone sort
of reports in the in in the unit of
kilograms
but what if we ask you
something like
if you're asking you about
more parking enforcement versus less
parking enforcement in berkeley right is
there sort of a consistent unit that
everyone's going to report
and what if these values are not
one-dimensional the lines are more
complex space which as a mechanism
designer you don't actually understand
so
but quite often
even though you might not understand the
underlying space
the median is still
well defined you can define the median
in general for a general space is just
the point that minimizes the distance
to the ideal positions of all the voters
and this is rated the condorcet winner
in some
in some very interesting ways
so is the problem clear our goal is to
extract the median
vote
of
a bunch of voters right but we don't
actually we might not have a consistent
vocabulary in which they'll express
their preferences right so there's
there's no way for them to describe that
my vote is
uh the point two three comma four in
this three dimensional space but
distances are somehow
able to be discussed
so there exists some space
so there exists some space and so so
in fact
uh i didn't mention it because it'll
take a long time to describe it for
example eliot has a paper which which
does a very nice job of this you assume
that there's some underlying space
but nobody can articulate what their
spaces right but it exists and people
sort of report
so so people are report people can sort
of do simple computations on that space
so for example you can make out whether
in this way something is closer to you
than something else right
but you can't
you have no common vocabulary for either
expressing that space or expressing
distance in that space
that's what can be talked about and i
guess
what can be talked about and
like and you'll get to that right so you
can express your own position
so there's some way in which you can say
what your position is you just can't
situate it
you just can't situate in this
underlying space
so
so of course
in this model you can expect people to
compare proposals so for example in the
previous talk you were every voter was
being able to ask to compare two
candidates but you could perhaps do more
perhaps you could ask questions like
which proposal is closest to x and sort
of between y and z
and the question is if you're given
premise of this form where people still
can't express they
can't quite articulate where they're in
a space but they can answer questions of
this type
then given more detailed
questions that people can ask
can you do more detailed computations
like extracting the median
so we want to identify a magic box and a
magic box is some calculation that a
user can do and see if we can use that
magic box to derive
to actually get median estimates from a
crowd
so
one simple thing is
one building that you could say suppose
suppose we could suppose we are given
the following primitives suppose given
three people
we could identify their one median right
so so three individuals can together
figure out what their one median is
so
so let's assume that we are given this
box and let's see what we could do
so let's think of the following
cartoon game
let's assume that all all individuals
are
in this some complicated matrix space
let's say this tree represents the
metric space from which individual
opinions are drawn
we have a box
we we take all the participants we put
them in the in a box
we take them three at a time
so we draw three participants at random
from this box
now these three participants also
these three participants
correspond to
these three positions in the underlying
metric space
and they can somehow magically compute
their one median
and report it back to you
so these three participants can can
figure out that the one me they're one
median in this underlying space
happens to be this yellow opinion this
yellow opinion happens to correspond to
one of the participants
and so this so essentially this opinion
or this participant is essentially the
winner of this triadic election
now of course
for the simple case of where
participants lie on a line
this median this this median opinion
would just be one of the three
participants
in fact it would be it would be the
middle of the three participants
and so
so what you do is you take this winner
and you remove
all three of these participants
from your box
and you add
three copies of the same participant
back to the box
and what that means is
in your box in the next time you draw a
random sample from this box
this yellow participant is four times as
likely to be drawn
as any other as any other participant
yes
you remove the three that you had drawn
so you draw three uniformly at random
you take their median
you remove the c that you already drawn
and you add
three additional copies of the yellow
guy back to this box
so if these points happen to lie on a
line then the yellow would be one of if
you assume that the underlying metric
space is a line
then this yellow guy would be one of the
three participants
right
but if it's not in a line that this may
not be another three partition
and so
so somehow this is easiest easiest to
understand this mechanism on the line so
but i should just
restrict myself to the line but the line
is a bit too stylized
so now we have four yellow guys in this
box we again draw three more
and these are the three that we end up
drawing
in this case the median actually happens
to be the blue point one of the
participants
so we'll add three copies of the blue
guy
and now we have three yellow three blue
one white and one brown
we keep repeating this process okay
and the winner is remaining what happens
if the median is not one of the colors
in the box
then this whole approach is going to
sort of not work
so what you have in mind no sorry the
median is not one of the colors in the
box that's okay okay the problem is if
the median is a non-participant sorry
then this approach is not going to work
so if i was to think about this what you
have in mind is i pick up three people
i i find that the medium consensus is
one of the one of the people in the box
then yeah i'm over sampling that guy so
then i can ask that guy to give his
preferences over some complicated that's
exactly right
and so
so so
so there's a big assumption here and the
big assumption is they're two big
assumptions here one big assumption is
that uh people can actually compute
their medians
and another big assumption is that uh
that median whatever they compute is
going to be one of the participants in
this
in this election right
procedure where you make more of that
guy
where are you getting these copies
so uh so since all we are using these
copies is for sampling making a copy of
an individual is just increasing the
sampling rate
so yes
so what happens if uh
you know they pick out one of their
three opinions for the one that
minimizes the sum of the distances so
that's like an approximate median does
it still
work out so i think that's the one that
we want to really prove properties about
so i think that that will sort of
address all the issues that are being
brought up
if you could say instead of if if you
could say the following if you could say
instead of finding the one million of
these
three individuals
if you could say a you would among b and
c b word among a and c c word among a
and b
if one of you happens to receive two
words
then we add three copies of that person
to the
box
otherwise if the three of you can't
agree among yourselves then there's no
way you're going to help my
decision-making process i'm going to
kick all three of you out
that's
that's the one that's the if you were to
deploy something that's the one that you
would actually deploy
and the small scale experiment that i
described that's not that's that's what
we actually did
so like if a group gets deadlocked then
we just say like
we'll ignore you
and if in a group a winner emerges then
we put them in
now but like i said today we're going to
talk about something stylized i can't
actually prove any theorems about this
so the one that the article will will
address all these questions
because then you don't have to worry
about is this space fully populated you
know and then it also answered this
question which i had which is how will
these three people find their own median
because
right now to find their own medium they
have to know the entire space
but if you're just voting among the
other two then you just sit down in a
small group and you talk
but the nice thing is that when you if
you assume that your voters lie on a
line then the two approaches go inside
because in the median of any three it's
going to just be the same
the median just going to be one of them
so at some point
everything will become one color and you
can say the winner is that color or you
could after some point most of
you'll have mostly two colors remaining
or there'll be some colors which will
dominate and you can say the winner this
is the distribution that i get
so just to ask
can someone guess what would happen if
we ran this process on this tree right
let's say there's a tree of height a
million
and
can someone guess like with high
probability will we choose the winner
among the top 500 000 right
which would give you like a square root
which would be like you're saying you're
choosing one of the top square root and
guys this guy this top guy is clearly
the median
or will be like a thousand which is
the square root of the height or 20
which is the log of the height or two
what would
suppose i would run that process on this
tree
what
h is the height of the tree
and the question is where do you think
the with high probability where do you
think the winner would come from
yeah i mean i wouldn't have asked the
question otherwise the winner would
indeed come so with high probability it
doesn't actually matter what the height
of the tree is with high probability if
you repeat this process
the the winner of this
simple dynamic right would be one of the
top two guys in the tree yeah
yes
understand the effect of the network
structure very well i guess
so so this is yeah sorry i should have
clarified there's no network
so there's so you voter opinions are
coming from some underlying underlying
space
and so imagine that there's a imagine
that there's a metric space which
underlies uh
uh
which
there's underlying metric space
everyone every opinion every versus
opinion is a point in this metric space
and in this case what i'm saying is the
metric space happens to form a binary
tree
so the distance between this opinion
this opinion is two
between this opinion and this opinion is
also two between this and this is uh one
two three four five
so this this binary tree is not it's not
a social
network in the sense of somebody knowing
somebody else it's sort of the is the
metric space just tells me the distance
between two opinions
sorry so the definition of the median in
this case is the node that's closest to
halfway between the the shortest path
connecting two nodes
so for two nodes the median may not be
very well defined for two nodes the
median could be
any one which is
for for two nodes the median could be
anyone along the shortest path
what is the definition of the medium
then there's a center
okay yeah
yeah it's exactly what i said for three
points the median is well defined
but three points the median would be
exactly the point where they they
diverge
so you take the short if if you look at
these three points so of course the
definition of the median the exact
structure would differ from problem
problem but in this case if i would take
this guy this guy and this guy
then this would be the median
because
this pink guy lies on the shortest path
from the blue to the black
lies on the shortest path
from the blue to the brown and lies on
the shortest path from this green to the
any of them
so in this particular case in the in the
tree case the median is exactly what i
said in general the median is just
whichever point happens to minimize the
sum of the distances to your three
chosen participants
that you asked us about
so
winner is chosen from the top d levels
with high probability
iterations
so so let's
the final one
let's keep let's keep running it till we
have one winner
and then i'm of course hit the
complexity i hit the
so if you have a square grade of size
uh like a million one times a million
one
right so you have like a big grid with a
trillion dollars then with high
probability
with 99 probably the winner will come
from the central three by three good
right so so essentially this very simple
process sounds like it's very it sounds
like it couldn't possibly lead to
uh very good results but if you run it
at least for these
stylized cases of a tree and a grid
uh it it finds you something which is
almost exactly the median
and so here's the here's the basic proof
argument so again i'm not going to give
a full proof but i'm going to at least
give intuition for the tree case
so what happens in the tree case is
imagine that
so in fact for the tree case let's just
to understand what happens in the trees
let's just focus on one edge
suppose you focus on just this one edge
then
let's color everybody who's on one side
of this edge red and everyone knows on
the other side of the edge blue
then we
pick so and then let's write down the
number of blue points we have on a line
so right now we have three blue points
so we say that we at this point
with this this coloring corresponds to
point number three
then let's
uh draw three
draws draw a sample of size three from
this uh
from this set right there three red
points so we choose a red point with
probably three then a blue point with
priority five eighths we draw three
samples
the mean the median of these three
happens to be
this individual
so now we're going to throw away the
three samples that we had already chosen
and we're going to add three copies of
this
of this individual who's blue
so we're going to now have two blue
points
and
six sorry two red points and six blue
points so you move from the point three
to the point two
in general at any given time
we are going to so any and at any given
point it's easy to see that we are 0.4
we can either remain at point four for
example if we draw all three red all
three blue will remain where we are
or whichever we draw less of that number
is going to go down by one so
essentially doing a random walk on this
line
and
uh the the reason that as far as this is
concerned all that matters is whether a
point is blue or red if if two points
happen to be on this side of the line
then the median will be on this side of
the line if they have if you have two
red points then the medium will be on
that side of the line
and then this ends up being a fairly
simple
recursion to write if you had point i
then
uh you're going to move to point i plus
one
precisely if you do if you draw exactly
two red and one blue and that's going to
happen with probability i over n squared
times n minus i over n
i'll ignore this factor three
and if you end up drawing one blue and
two red then you you're going to move
right
so so now you have this fairly simple
markov chain which is describing what's
happening on a tree
and
then sort of uh
given this
given this very simple markov chain
you can write down the probability that
the winner is going to be red
given any number of initial right people
first people and then also you can
analyze the time tabs option we're going
to have all blue or all red
and
so this probably that whether
red wins given
given the initial point that you start
is actually the one that gives you this
fact that i mentioned before that the
winner is going to be on the top two
levels
and by analyzing the absorption time of
this markov chain you can actually say
that the time to absorption is going to
be n log n which is the question that
eva was
implicitly asking
but the probabilities yeah with high
probability
but the probability at least for the
trick is so high that it's not not even
worth
writing
because what happens for the tree
is that basically you want to
you want to understand what's the
probability
that this tree wins but this three if
you think of this tree as being red this
tree has only n over four elements so
it's going to win with almost minuscule
probability the same with this the same
for this and the same for this so with
very high probability you're going to be
in one of the three
did you have a question
so in general these
in general this is easy to enter it's
easy to believe the same thing the same
you can use the same method for the for
the grid i'll skip this
so in general it seems like for the line
it makes sense for the tree it makes
sense it might make sense for the grid
but in fact it makes sense for a
slightly larger class of glass
for any medium graph
and a medium graph is any graph where
every three notes have a unique median
so in in a tree
somehow uh i skipped over by there's a
unique medium but in a tree any three
nodes have a unique median
so in any graph where everything does
have a unique median uh triadic
consensus finds a one plus order square
root log n over n approximation
to the one median in order n log n nouns
and so is this
is this a reasonable thing right so we
said suppose that we asked could find
their one median right is there a
reasonable thing can we actually expect
these three ads to find their one median
or is there a simpler primitive that we
could pro we could ask them to implement
so that simple primitive could lead to
one median
and the simple primitive actually
so first of all
so this is so first of all one medium is
already somewhat reasonable because
for triads and median if you have a
median graph
then the one median is the same as the
condorcet winner
for these three
uh these three participants
and then of course if when voters lie on
the line then the one median is just the
middle water in the triad
but you can also you also have a box you
can also
replace this by a simple problem
and you can also say
if a voter can ask the following
question answer the following question
what proposal is closest to x
x being me
and between y and z
and if a voter can answer this simple
question as opposed to finding the full
median
if anyone is interested there's a very
interesting lecture to stand for
tomorrow
so i'm going to skip the details but if
you can get individuals to answer
questions of this type which proposal is
closest to me
and between y and z
then you can use that that as the magic
box to then construct a one medium magic
box
i'm going to skip details of exactly how
you do it
but basically what happens is you have a
chooser and two proposals the proposers
keep take turns proposing a proposing
a solution
and the chooser either says okay i like
it better
uh and accepts it
or says
no i don't like the one that you now
propose and rejects it in which case
whatever was accepted last becomes a
winner okay i i know i went through it
very fast i don't actually expect you to
get the details of this side
but
but i want to i want to mention so but i
said somewhere here that this is
in this case
uh
for everyone to participate truthfully
for every tr to truthfully find the one
median is a nash equilibrium
and uh i i want to just
instead of giving details for the proof
i want to explain what i mean by nash
equilibrium
so i'm going to assume that participants
are not strategic in declaring their
positions so the positions that the
participants declare
are non-strategic they're just truthful
by
by fiat
but the strategy space so the strategy
space is not what positions they declare
but the words that they cast in any
triadic interaction
and then if we assume that then we can
show that truthful voting is a nash
equilibrium in the entire extensive form
game over the entire n log n steps
and this assumption may be too strong
right that participants are not
strategic in declining positions
the assumption is too strong then sort
of
the two ways of thinking of this
one is can you think of designing the
right mechanism right think of that as
an open problem right so don't think of
what we did as a result think of it as
an open problem right
or you can just interpret this result
only as an analysis of the dynamics with
truthful voters
and just leave strategic issues aside
altogether
so
so at the beginning i mentioned that the
complexity one complexity parameter of
interest here is
the size of the group and so the natural
question is well we can do something
with triads can we do something with
just two people at a time can we have
group sizes of two as these two people
engage in some interaction aggregate
their opinions and still find a good
approximation of the median
and as it
as it turns out
so could you could you have a magic box
where you put people two at a time
uh replace them with something else and
then ultimately hope to get to the
median and that turns out to be
impossible
so no reasonable pairwise magic box or
no reasonable pairwise aggregation
function can find an approximate one
median even in median graphs
and this
this are the way to think about this is
when you have three individuals they
provide an incurring effect
so if the three individuals fight then
me as a participant can distinguish
tense among i can say that person is
extreme
because i don't like him or her and this
other person also doesn't like him or
her with two individuals there's no
incurring effect
so it's not surprising but as it turns
out for a very simple
there's a very simple notion of local
consistency
which says that
if uh given any group if the groups look
internally the same then the outcome has
to be the same
you can show that no two percent locally
consistent reduction can approximate the
median up to anywhere like one plus
small over one
and the graph that
the the metric space that shows that
counter example is just this
metric space where you have a big star
and then a long line hanging of the big
star
i think i'm out of time so i'm going to
just i'm going to stop
with the first observation that
what we talked about today was very
stylized whereas i started with this
participatory democracy example
and in the in the talk on the
algorithmic algorithms
sorry go to the game theory in practice
workshop i'm going to focus more on the
deployments that we did as opposed to
stylized models
and then
some problems here are can we generalize
as past median spaces so media spaces
are very broad they include
they include trees grits
hypercubes they include anything called
a reduction of the hypercube but they're
still not as general as all metric
spaces so can we generalize as pass
metric spaces can we use other magic
magic boxes as opposed to triers finding
their own median
can we constrain the winner of a triadic
interaction to be a participant in the
triad okay and it still proves wrong
with us so in my mind that would really
make it a practical protocol
can we have stronger incentive alignment
than the one that we showed
can we do experimental studies of small
group consensus are there other small
group mechanisms which are very
different from creating
and and then once you understand the
space of this the design is a little bit
better
can we do an exomatic treatment of the
problem
or is there some sort of more detailed
metamodel of the problem that we are
missing if you were to write that meta
model in the right algorithm would
present itself
so i think thank you
yes so do you know that
your algorithm does not work for some
graphs
well if if it's not a median space then
the notion of a median is not even well
defined
right so there's no such thing as a
median
if it's not a median graph
so
because in in the sense that given three
individuals there may be many many many
medians
and so
uh so i don't quite know how to analyze
it
so we do know that there are examples
there exist artificial examples where if
you constrain the winner of the triadic
interaction to be a participant in the
triad
then we don't get then we cannot recover
the results that we have exactly as they
are
so in
in my mind
in so once again even though i said this
before in my mind the reason something
like this is very attractive
it's because this does not make any
assumptions about is there one median is
there two medians are there like many
medians
or which median are you picking and how
do you pick the median
so for this specific thing we do have
counter examples where our results are
stated don't hold
but perhaps there's some other way of
analyzing this which you're missing
so you could add i would say only small
noise to the distances and everything
would come to median space right
you could you have a finite metric space
you you picked up the
distances
no i mean unfortunately not
so the kind of thing that you're
describing might be very useful in
analyzing this protocol where you have
to choose one of the three but if you're
actually trying to find the median
then the problem is that
in median graphs
is any any is a graph where every three
notes have a unique median
and so
uh
but
the way we are using it right we are
assuming that this median space is fully
populated
so you might be able to enforce
uniqueness of a median by perturbing the
space
but you pick the median and there's no
participant corresponding the median
that you picked
and so that that problem you can't solve
by perturbing but you could solve that
problem if you constrain the winner of a
triading interaction to be one of the
three members of the triad
so i think that so i think yeah so the
fact that the media whether the median
is unique or not i think it's a smaller
problem and then the bigger problem is
the median may not even be populated
what happens if there is noise in the
sense that it doesn't move exactly to
the median but maybe
so i don't quite know how to analyze it
for general median graphs because the
general median graphs the proof gets
very technical because you have to sort
of take all sorts of convex cells but
for the simple the simple random walk
that i had that is very robust
so you can move it around because also
what happens is that that walk is very
strongly biased towards one direction
versus the other so small noises won't
change that particular so for for a tree
or for a grader for a line it would be
very robust
so we're quite a bit over uh so let's
thank should